لقد غادر الرئيس بايدن إسرائيل والمنطقة
بعد فشله في عقد تلك القمة
مع القادة العرب، فلنذهب الآن إلى ماران
ماشا الذي كان سفير الأردن إلى
إسرائيل ثم وزير الخارجية الأردني
مرحبًا بك في برنامج ماران، هل
يمكنني أن أسألك أولاً وقبل
كل شيء كيف سيكون رد فعلك؟  الآن إلى
كون ملككم رئيس
مصر رئيس
السلطة الفلسطينية أه ألغى قمتهم مع
الرئيس بايدن لأنهم صدقوا أفترض ولهذا
السبب اعتقدوا أن
إسرائيل ضربت ذلك المستشفى المعمداني
في غزة هل كان
متسرعا أعتقد الرأي العام المسيحي
أه بعد الهجوم على المستشفى لم
يكن يسمح بعقد القمة
الجمهور العربي يضع الهجوم
بشكل مباشر أه على إسرائيل وفي ظل هذه
الظروف أه كان من
الصعب للغاية أن تنعقد القمة
هذه واحدة وأعتقد أيضا أنه
كان هناك  لا ضمانات بأن القمة
ستؤدي إلى
وقف إطلاق النار وأه كان الجمهور
يشكك في
فائدتها أه بسبب ذلك
وأعتقد السبب الثالث هو أنه إذا
شعر الإسرائيليون أن إيران متواطئة
مع حماس في هذا الهجوم فالجمهور العربي
أيضا  يشعرون أنه لا يوجد فرق
بين موقف الإدارة الأمريكية
وموقف إسرائيل،
ويشعرون أيضًا أن هناك
عملية تجريد
الفلسطينيين من إنسانيتهم ​​تحدث عندما
يكون هناك ضحايا إسرائيليون، وتشعر أن
هناك الكثير من التعاطف من قبل
المجتمع الدولي ولكن هذا التعاطف
هناك نقص عندما يتعلق الأمر بالفلسطينيين،
وفي ظل هذه
الظروف، أعتقد أنه
كان من الصعب للغاية عقد القمة، هل
يمكنني فقط المضي
قدمًا قليلاً في ما تقوله بغض النظر عن
الأدلة وقد
أكدت الولايات المتحدة الأدلة بشكل مستقل
أن الشارع العربي رغم ذلك لا
يعتقد أن
إسرائيل هي كذلك، نعم ولكن هل هذا
مستدام
للمستقبل؟ أعتقد أن هناك حاجة
لإجراء تحقيق مستقل،
لن أقول من فعل ذلك
ولكن هناك أيضًا
مؤشرات قوية أه من الطرف الآخر
مثلا أن نفس المستشفى تم استهدافه
بالصواريخ الإسرائيلية يوم السبت الماضي
رئيس أساقفة كانتربري جاستن ويلبي وهو أه
طبعا كنيسته
المسؤولة عن المستشفى أه وضع شيئا
على TW أه على تويتر يوم السبت الماضي يقول
ذلك  أه تم قصف مستشفاه
وهناك أربعة إصابات أه اليوم فقط
وضع بيان آخر أه أه تعرف
يكرر تلك الحقيقة كذلك الفلسطيني أه
مسؤولو المستشفى قالوا أيضًا إنهم
تلقوا تحذيرات من الجيش الإسرائيلي
بعد الهجوم الأول لإخلاء
المستشفى لذلك أنا  لا تعتقد أننا نستطيع إصدار
حكم قبل أن نتمكن من رؤية أنك تعرف
أدلة قوية حول من فعل ذلك، ولكن
أبعد من من فعل ذلك، أيها المسيحي، أبعد من من
فعل ذلك، فهذه مقدمة لهذا النوع
من المذبحة التي سنراها إذا
غزت إسرائيل  غزة وأخشى أننا
قد نرى عشرات الآلاف من
الضحايا إذا ذهبت إسرائيل بالفعل إلى غزة
التي لا يمكن أن تكون تحت سيطرة إسرائيل، كما تعلمون،
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها.
العقاب الجماعي الذي يقطع المياه عن
مليوني فلسطيني لا يمكن التغاضي عنه
أو تبريره باسم  الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسها هو القانون الدولي
والذي يجب أن تحترمه إسرائيل أه أه كما تعلم
لدرجة أننا
تحدثنا بوضوح مع مارتن غريفيث وربما
سمعت أنه يبدو أن هناك
اتفاق أه وهو بالطبع
نحن  سوف نتابع ونراقب
لنرى ما إذا كان سيتم
البدء فعليًا في السماح أه تعرف الماء وكل ما
تبقى ولكنك على حق أه
وزير الدفاع أه دعا إلى
حصار كامل وحصار على غزة الأسبوع الماضي ومن
الواضح أن هذا هو  إنها مسألة كبيرة أه
تثير قلق الولايات المتحدة والجميع في
المنطقة، لكن هل يمكنني أن أسألك هذا، هل
أنت موجود منذ
فترة طويلة طوال طريق العودة إلى
اتفاقيات السلام الأصلية في أوسلو وما تلاها من نتائج؟
أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أن
هناك خطرًا من احتمال تورط إيران وحزب الله الآخرين
بشكل أكبر في
رد الفعل العنيف تجاه إسرائيل في الوقت
الحالي، لا أعتقد في هذه المرحلة
كريستيان أن الحسبة ستتدخل،
والحسبة تفهم أنها إذا
فعلت أه ذلك  أه قد أه أه أه تواجه
ضربة قوية لبنيتها
التحتية أه لدينا خمس
توغلات إسرائيلية لغزة خلال
العشرين سنة الماضية والحسبة لم
تشارك في أي منها واحد منهم كان عمره
51 سنة أه يوم أه تعرف التوغل
لذلك  ما لم يكن هناك شيء هائل
يغير المعادلة، لا
أعتقد أن الحسبة ستتدخل.
أريد أن أسألك هذا لأنني
أتذكر بالتأكيد منذ سنوات عديدة مضت،
ذهب ملكك الملك الحسين أم إلى إسرائيل
وركع عند أقدام والدي
من الذين قُتلوا إسرائيليين
قُتلوا على يد إرهابي أردني وهو في
الأساس كما تعلمون قدموا
التعازي وطلبوا
المغفرة لديكم اتفاقية سلام
مع أه مع إسرائيل في أعقاب
ما حدث في 7 أكتوبر هل
لديك أي أمل في السلام
يمكن استئناف الاتفاق بأي شكل من الأشكال في النهاية
أنا لا أفعل ذلك على المدى القصير
وأقول لك لماذا كريستيان الذي
سيبدأ عملية السلام أه
الأمريكيين منشغلون بانتخاباتهم
العام المقبل أه ليس لديهم
مزاج لم يفعلوا  كنت في مزاج
لبدء المفاوضات طوال السنوات التسع الماضية
منذ أن تخلى جون كاري آخر مرة عن
جهود السلام
السلطة الفلسطينية في
أضعف حالاتها أه والحكومة الإسرائيلية
أه وهي حكومة متشددة جدا بلا حقوق
ليست في مزاج
لم تكن في مزاج  حتى قبل هذا أه
بالنسبة لأي تسوية سياسية فقد
أوضحوا أنهم لا
ينوون إنهاء الاحتلال ولكن
بالمناسبة يجب ذكر الاحتلال الذي تعرفونه
لأن هذا هو السبب الجذري
لما نراه وعلينا أن نضعه
في سياقه  ما يحدث ولكن
الحكومة الإسرائيلية ليست في مزاج للقيام
بكل هذا فمن سيقود
عملية
المفاوضات أه أريد أيضًا أن أقول
شيئًا آخر هو أننا لا نستطيع الاستمرار في هذه
الدوامة من العنف ومفاوضات السلام
التي تؤدي إلى  إذا كانت هناك عملية في أي مكان،
وأنا للأسف لا
أتوقعها، فيجب أن تكون عملية تهدف
إلى إنهاء الاحتلال. وإذا
لم ينته الاحتلال، فأنا أخشى
أن تستمر دائرة العنف هذه على كلا
الجانبين.